hello my name is David Haws and as you
can see from the title the subject is
going to be crowd : protein crystals and
other macro molecular crystals the
reason that crystals are crowd cold is
so that they reduce radiation damage
during synchrotron x-ray detection I did
this work on cryo cooling the very first
protein crystal back in 1967 and then I
enough science in 1970 and discover that
in fact it was being used until just a
few years ago it turns out that the
message that I'm going to deliver today
is in fact that research the to publish
your scientific research in
peer-reviewed journals will in fact
could possibly be used years and years
ahead when you can't even foresee what
would happen and that's exactly what
happened to me the article I published
in 1970 was read and has been used very
successfully today by thousands of
scientists around the world in all types
of synchrotron radiation so I'm going to
tell you the story and in fact this is a
picture taken to me when I worked in
crystallography for five years between
1965 and 1970 and then I joined industry
so this is when I was a graduate student
collecting data at the University of
offal in 1965 I went on a my first
postdoc and it was with David Phillips
at the Royal Institution in London in
fact you can see here that lysozyme
molecule he had just solved the
structure in 1965 and when I arrived he
had suggested a project for me and I
looked at trying to reduce radiation
damage and protein crystals so I worked
on that for a year and a half at the
Royal Institution with David Phillips
and of course at that time so his bride
was actually the director so he was very
interested in the subject also year and
a half I had no he's also whatsoever and
then I enough the Royal Institution went
to the Weizmann Institute soon after
that and I'll tell you that story later
on but the important fact is that
three dimensional structures of protein
crystals have become very important and
it's actually created an entire new
field called structural biology in 1971
the protein data bank was begun and this
is a picture of the various proteins
there are nine protein structures all in
1973 the protein data bank has basically
become the heart of molecule Balaji it
is the resource where all the structures
of macromolecules are saved and today
there were more than 150,000 structures
that have been deposited and both
proteins nucleic acids DNA and a number
of other macromolecules one of the most
remarkable things is that each year now
about 10,000 new structures are being
deposited that's about 50 a day and the
data is being collected the crystal data
for x-rays is being collected on
synchrotrons so I only discovered this
just a few years ago and when I went to
my scientific meeting in 19 in 2015 I
was given a copy of this magazine which
is a special issue of journal marco
balaji 50 years of protein structure
and Max Perutz and of course John
Kendrew
were the two scientists who determined
the very first protein structures but
today it is 60 years 2019 since the
first protein structures were solved and
it's been 52 years since the first cryo
cooling of protein crystal the protein
data bank has increased in the number of
of structures dramatically and what is
surprising is that about 90 percent of
all these structures and the protein
data bank have been cryo cold meaning
that the data was collected at about a
hundred degrees Kelvin from the Journal
of molecular Z issue there was a
paragraph that said that's three most
significant things for the creation of
structural biology field is
in fact the invention of the synchrotron
our cryo calling of crystals which
permit them to be used and of course the
high speed computers and the remarkable
computer programs and software has been
developed to solve the structures and
just to amplify on that a little bit
this is the synchrotron at Brookhaven
National Laboratory there are 50
synchrotrons similar to this around the
world and they are available to all
scientists our synchrotron produces
x-rays about 10 million times more
intense than the vacuum tubes that I use
with 10 million times just remarkable
you can collect the data on a single
crystal in a matter of minutes whereas
in in the 1960s it would take months or
years data and of course the
synchrotrons now that they provide such
an intense x-ray source the crystals are
protected by cryo cooling and simply
putting the crystals in the liquid
nitrogen and that's exactly the way it
was done in 1967 I thought I'm going to
tell you about in the third thing of
course is the Magnificent their computer
software and hardware that is available
today that permits through motion
instructions not only to be solved but
also the graphic interfaces that permit
you to visualize them but there is also
a fourth area and that is in fact of the
cloning to be able to produce proteins
of purification of proteins and a third
area which is the crystallization of
proteins which have become an entire
field in itself just the ability we will
crystallize these enormous
macromolecules so this really is a Back
to the Future story this is the story
that happened to me and that's what I
want to relate to you as young scientist
or graduate students basically should
realize that once you publish your
scientific results in a peer-reviewed
journal it could be used anytime in the
future and this actually the future
story that I'm telling you is is exactly
what happened to me 50 years later I
discovered that the work that I did
which I had totally forgotten about I
discovered was very valuable so in 1970
Michael Rothman and I published the
paper the second paper on cryo cooling
and the purpose and it was taken on
electric to hydrogen ice crystals cryo
cooled and we showed that in fact the
radiation damage at room temperature is
much more severe than it is at cryo cool
in fact we showed that there's a in a
provement of ten times the life of the
crystal at low temperatures today it's
synchrotrons typically they consider the
crystals to have 70 times or more a
lifetime in the x-ray beam so this is
the first quantitative proof and it came
out of this 1970 paper so let me just
review with you basically my five years
in crystallography and basic science
after graduating from University of
Buffalo with David Harker we arranged
for a postdoc at the Royal Institution
of Great Britain they were trolls had
just finished working on lysozyme
structure and in fact so Lawrence Bragg
was the director after working a year
and a half on not having any results
whatsoever on reducing the radiation
damage I went to the Weizmann Institute
because he David Phillips had taken
their position in Oxford and upon
arriving at the wife and I decided
they'd already couldn't support all my
supplies with me and I continued to work
on the radiation damage probably project
for about three more months in March of
1967 I decided that it was absolutely
hopeless I needed to find some other
alternative and what I did in fact was
made a list of all the alternatives that
I could take over and I chatted with
wolfie trial who was the director of the
crystallography lab and I concluded that
cryocooler looked like the most
promising and as fate would have it a
wolfie trial had just built a crackling
apparatus about five years before and it
was sitting in the laboratory
unused so and not only that he said I
could use it as well as the technician
who was currently in the lab is the one
who built it and he would teach me how
to use it so I was able to cry oh cool
Isis I'm crystals with with our
cryoprotectants they gave pristine
diffraction patterns like this one and
then in fact after leaving in the beam
day after day after day
there was no change and this is the
first indication that I had that in fact
there was some protection or there was
real radiation reduction in this
lysozyme crystal so this paper was
published from the Weissman and then the
six-day war occurred in June of 1967
I had already arranged with Michael
Grossman at Purdue University to go
there and I arrived in late 1967 at
Purdue my project that I wanted to work
on with Michael was to show
quantitatively that in fact radiation
reduction is is performed and I was able
to convince Michael by showing him those
wonderful precession pictures from the
weitzman then in fact I could do the
project so he loaned me just a fractal
meter and I built this equivalent at the
Purdue in 1967 and we collected all the
data during the summer of 1968 after
that we wrote the paper and this was I
was published in in April of 1969 as the
house and Ross made paper we submitted
it in July of 68 and basically the most
important part of that paper was in fact
this drawing of the radiation decay
which clearly shows a tenfold
improvement in radiation reduction
damage in a quarrel state soon after
that I had given a number of papers on
this result and the crime
of protein crystals and a number of
scientific meetings and basically at
each of the meetings there were no
questions and Network people said it's
nice work but it has absolutely no
application so besides having a little
depression from that I also decided I
really wasn't fit for academia and I
joined industry so in 1970 through basic
in 2015 I was out of the academic world
in 2015 as I said as I went to my
American crystallographic Association
meeting and I started learning about
structural biology I was invited to
attend the x-ray methods course at Cold
Spring Harbor Laboratory and that was
2017 16 days of intense study but the
most remarkable part was that the first
week we grew lysozyme crystals we
cryocooler them and then we sent him to
the Brookhaven synchrotron and collected
all the data in a matter of minutes I
can tell you one of my surprises was
walking into the hutch the x-ray thought
you had a synchrotron which is what this
photograph is I say the instrumentation
looked so fantastic and I didn't
recognize any of it except for the Dewar
liquid nitrogen door which basically was
the same Dewar that James Dewar had
invented back in 1892 so I didn't feel
so bad about that one of the remarkable
coincidence is that in 1892 James Dewar
did his work in exactly this at the
Royal Institution but it was also in
exactly the same laboratory that I did
my x-ray work when I was there in 1965
and I'm sure James Dewar would be very
impressed about how his invention is
being used today so the results of
structural biology and the protein data
bank basically produced an entire film
nation formal apology and I'm sure many
of you who are in the biological
sciences have come to appreciate the
value of having these remarkable
three-dimensional structures and data
available so in my second presentation
I'm going to tell you about how my
postdoctoral work 50 years later has
contributed substantially to structure
based drug design which has led to many
of the drugs that have been used for the
HIV epidemic and as I will specifically
show you the Lazarus effect which is one
of one of the phenomenas that happened
in 1996 during the HIV epidemic I also
like to thank the people who helped me
over the years as you might gather David
Phillips who suggested the original
project of reduced radiation damage
wolfie trial if he had not had in his
laboratory the crowd cooling equipment
that I used it probably never would have
gotten done probably 10 20 30 years
later Michael Rossman I think who
recognized the importance of having a
single crystal that showed reduced
radiation damage so you could collect
all your data and then I especially want
to thank Elspeth Carmen who was one of
the experts in radiation damage and has
taught me in a matter of months what I
did not learn in 50 years so the final
sentence should be science for the
benefit of humanity which is exactly
what I see structural biology has
contributed thank you
you